this is a production of cornell
university
okay so as nina just demonstrated
soils are composed of different
percentages of different sized particles
sand silt and clay we have a technique
we can demonstrate now that will give us
an approximation
of those representative percentages
those percentages are indicated on the
usda texture triangle which we also have
with us here
so this technique that's going to give
us an approximation
of the percentages is going to give us
an indication of the
soil texture and so at that
by running through this uh flow chart
here
we're going to end up with a sort of
rough estimation of the texture of these
two samples of soil
so we have two samples here and i'm
going to start with
this one here and we're just going to
run through the process
on our flowchart so it starts with
taking a small amount of soil
in the hand this is soil texture by feel
or by hand and we're gonna we're gonna
sort the soil a little bit
removing sticks and stones uh
elements like larger than the largest
particle sand
that do not form part of the overall
textural composition
so i'm just pulling out the stones uh
looking for some of these are just large
particles of soil that are kind of glued
together
i'm just going to remove those i'm
trying to get down here to just the
basic
composition of the soil here again i'm
just kind of
sieving them out filtering them out
okay last pieces of gravel here
all right once i have what is pretty
much just the soil left
these are just field soils just dug
i'm going to wet the sample i'm going to
place just a couple drops
and the goal here is to form a ball i
want to get a ball of soil
that's you know roughly putty-like
inconsistency
uh something that kind of holds together
so we're going to keep wetting
until uh we get there
add a little more soil we want about a
little golf ball size so we have enough
to
run our diagnostic on
mixing it in my hand
what we're going for here is we want the
soil to form a ball
this is the first part of the the test
if it will form a ball
okay but there we go we're pretty close
a little more
no you're just about there when your
hands are
covered in dirt
okay now reading through our flow chart
uh the first questions it's
it'll ask is will will the
sample form a ball uh when squeezed
right so i'm going to give it a little
squeeze and it retains its shape
if it then wants to just kind of shatter
and fall apart
following through the diagnostic we end
up with that your sample is sand
so this is not just sand uh we move on
okay so the the next uh
part of this test is to try to form a
ribbon and
the ability of the soil sample to form a
ribbon and hold
it is going to be a measure of the
percentage of clay
okay so
to form a ribbon you can take the sample
in your
palm of your hand like this and you
start to kind of squeeze
and feed it out and you want
it to break naturally and fall okay to
the table
there it goes you do that a couple times
and each time
estimating the length so here we have
about three quarters of an inch
put it back into a ball form
it's dried out a little bit in my hand
feed it a little more water we don't
want water to be
squeezed out
okay going back to forming a ribbon
squeezing it out and
fell this time we hit about an inch okay
and we'll just do one more ribbon
and then we'll take the average of the
three
okay there it goes and it shattered when
it hit but
just under an inch okay so now
following through our our flowchart here
diagram
i'm reading yes we have a ball
and and the ribbon formation
we had an inch or less so we're in the
lone category right so the next
uh part of the test is to estimate the
percentage of
grit or sand in the in the sample so i'm
going to take
a little bit of it put the rest aside
about a teaspoon or two here
i'm gonna
wet it in the palm of my hand
and this process is intended to kind of
flatten it out
estimate the percentage of sand
as a factor of how gritty the soil
sample feels
okay so the the diagram asks us does the
sample feel very gritty equally gritty
and smooth
or very smooth so
kind of just got to give an estimation
here
it's somewhat gritty and somewhat smooth
it's kind of feels somewhere in the
middle
okay so the diagnostic has led us to
the conclusion then that this sample is
alone so i'm going to listen to the
sample
and see if i can hear the sound of the
grit rubbing
yeah and i can hear it just a little bit
it's somewhere between
a loam and a sandy loam then
and so if we turn to the texture
triangle we can actually then convert
that
diagnosis into percentages of
the various particle sizes right so
reading here
we have a sandy loam
being composed of something around 20
clay max and
somewhere between uh 70 to
50 sand
and a loam being as low as 30
sand so we're probably
somewhere down in that 30 percent to 40
range
below sandy loam yeah okay so let's try
the next sample
by appearance alone there's not really
much we can tell
they there's kind of
there's no way to visually distinguish
these two soils
in terms of their texture here but by
running through the soil texture by feel
we should be able to make some
conclusions
so make sure we get all the last sample
off
okay and again we're going to sort the
sample a little bit
moving some roots
so we have a sufficient quantity there
to get our ribbon
and wetting the soil
a little more it's still not quite
consolidating
just a little bit more
okay yeah that's starting to
form a little film on my hands so we
should be there you don't want to over
over saturate it okay going back to our
flowchart the first uh diagnostic
is to see if the sample will form a ball
and here we have a nice ball so
and under a little pressure from the
finger it doesn't fall apart doesn't
shatter
so we know we don't have a sand sample
as we suspected
and give it a little squeeze still con
stays together stays put so it's it's
not a sand or a loamy sand
so we're gonna move down into uh the
next step which is the ribbon forming
process
and get
teed up in my hand right and start
feeding it out
and right away i can tell that it's
forming a longer ribbon
this one broke when it hit but there we
have maybe an inch and a quarter
run that three times
i'm just gonna let it naturally just
feed over my forefinger
until it wants to fall okay
all right there may be almost two inches
and one last sample
all right maybe an inch and a half
so about an inch and a half average and
just under that
uh so reading across uh
we've gotten into the clay loam category
okay so now we need to estimate the
amount of grit in the sample so i'm
going to take a small portion of it
in the palm of my hand
and re-wet it in order to form a film
which i get a sense of the percentage
here
recalling that this relates back to the
percentages
of the various particles in the texture
triangle
okay already i can tell there's
some grit there certainly but
i'm not doing as much as the previous
sample at all
and i'm listening
there's a little little bit of sound of
friction but
not a lot certainly less than half
so we're more on the smooth side with
this one
reading down somewhere between
clay loam and a silty clay loam
so let's see going over here to the
texture triangle
finding a clay loam here and a silty
clay loam here
we can tell then that we're you know
somewhere between
uh 30 to 40 clay we didn't move
much but it definitely we didn't move
the percentage of clay
very far but it definitely changed the
the characteristic qualities of the
texture of the soil
so it became more smooth more capable of
forming a longer ribbon
uh with just a little bit more clay and
it changed the
just that small amount of adjustment
changed the soil texture for us in our
diagnostic
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu